We can think of diagnosis as a mapping from a data space, to a hypothesis space,
In case of a medical diagnosis, the data may be the greatest kind of signs and
symptoms that I may go to a doctor with. Some of the data may be very specific,
some of it may be very abstract, an example of a very
specific data is that a [UNKNOWN] temperature is 104 degrees fahrenheit.
An example of the extraction of the data is that [INAUDIBLE] is running a fever.
The hypothesis space consists of all hypothesis that can explain parts of
the observed data. A hypothesis in the hypothesis space can explain some part of
the data, In case of medicine, this hypothesis may reference to diseases.
A doctor may say that my hypothesis is that a shook is suffering from flu, and
that explains his high fever. In the domain of car repairs,
this hypothesis may refer to specific faults with the car, for example,
the carburetor is not working properly. In the domain of computer software,
this hypothesis may refer to specific methods not working properly.
And this mapping from data space to the hypothesis space can be very complex.
The complexity arises partly because of the size of data space, partly because
of the size of hypothesis space, partly because the mapping can be M to N. And
also, because this hypothesis can interact with each other, If H3 is present,
H4 may be excluded, If H5 is present, H6 is sure to be present and so
on. It helps then not to deal with all the raw data, but
to deal with abstractions of the data, so the initial data that a patient may
go to a doctor with may be very, very specific. The signs and
symptoms of their particular specific patient, but the diagnostic process might
abstract them from Asok has a fever of 104 degrees farenheit to Asok has
a high fever. This abstract data that can be mapped into an abstract hypothesis,
Asok has high fever can get mapped into Asok has a bladder infection for
example. The abstract hypothesis can now be refined into a suffering from flu or
a flu for a particular screen. At the end,
we want a hypothesis that is as refined as possible, and
that explains all the available data. When we were talking about classification,
we talked about two processes of classification, bottom-up process and
our top down process. The bottom up process of classification, we started with
raw data and then grouped and abstracted, it in case of top down classification
we started with some high level class and then established it and refined it.
You can see that in diagnosis both the bottom up process of classification, and
the tope down process of classification are co-occurring.
This method of bottom up classification and data space, mapping and
hypothesis space, and then top down classification of hypothesis space is called
heuristic classification. This is yet another method like rule-based reasoning,
case-based reasoning, and model-based reasoning with a diagnostic task.